now we are learning more about the lives
that were lost during this week's school
shooting in oxford michigan neighbors
are coming together to mourn and pray as
the alleged gunman faces murder and
terrorism charges yesterday the death
toll rose to four nancy chen reports
we didn't quit we came back we grinded
worked every day we trust each other we
all love each other sixteen-year-old
tate meer died on the way to the
hospital tate was honestly one of the
best people i've been privileged to know
in my life senior austin whitt played
football with meer he was always happy
cracking jokes
he was
he was honestly the heart and soul of
our team and probably our community
he's a true hero and
my thoughts and prayers go out to his
family
meer was one of the four teenagers
killed on tuesday along with 14 year old
hannah st juliana a member of the
basketball team 17 year old madison
baldwin who would have graduated next
year and 17 year old justin schilling
who is on the golf and bowling teams
on wednesday the alleged shooter ethan
crumbly pleaded not guilty sir do you
understand all the charges against you
yes i do investigators say there is a
mountain of digital evidence that
strongly suggests crumbly plan the
attack in advance evidence that law
enforcement officials say includes a
video he made the night before the
shooting that mentioned killing students
a journal recovered from his backpack
detailing his desire to shoot up the
school and social media postings of the
gun used in the attack purchased by his
father just four days before the
shooting prosecutor karen mcdonald says
the charges are clear charging this
person as an adult is necessary to
achieve justice and protect the public
the 15-year-old faces 24 charges
including four counts of first degree
murder and one count of terrorism
causing death
what about all the children who ran
screaming hiding under desks what about
all the children at home right now who
can't eat and can't sleep and can't
imagine a world where they could ever
step back foot back in that school those
are victims too
investigators say the alleged shooter
walked into a bathroom around 12 50 p.m
tuesday with a backpack and walked out
moments later with a semi-automatic
handgun firing more than 30 shots at
students it was horrific
it was really startling
hearing everyone come out and not
knowing where
the gunshots would be next senior
mitchell williams fled his classroom as
soon as he heard the gunshots it's
really sad and it's
no one knows really what to do because
of it and
it's uh
something that should have never
happened
nancy we are told that the suspect met
with school officials before the
shooting what can you tell us about that
nate that's right the county sheriff
told us that the alleged shooter met
twice with school officials this week
over behavioral issues the first was on
monday on his own the second was with
his parents just three hours before the
shooting took place and prosecutors say
those parents have not been cooperating
and they're considering bringing charges
against them as well the sheriff did
tell us that despite rumors his office
did not have advance notice about this
attack
nancy thank you